[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je pourrais vous parler du jour après
mon premier titre mondial ou du dernier
huit ans après je pourrais vous parler
aussi du jour où j'ai choisi de terminer
mes 15 ans de carrière
fraîchement diplômé de notre maison
commune l'essec
je pourrais aussi vous parler du jour où
j'ai osé
enfin danser le tango j'ai rencontré mon
compagnon et nous avons ensemble décidé
de fonder une famille et d'avoir deux
merveilleux enfants qui nous comble de
joie
est ce que je me suis donné les moyens
de vivre ses bonheurs oui est ce que
j'ai de la chance
oui ses choix et ses décisions je les
dois ce qui m'a construite le sport le
sport m'a permis de connaître mon corps
et c'est parce que j'ai connecté
celui-ci à mon mental que je suis forte
confiante et parce que si celui ci en le
mettant en mouvement j'ai aiguiser les
sens j'ai identifié mes émotions je les
ai acceptées et je les ai maîtrisé j'ai
aussi jubilé de voir mon corps se
transformer dans sa toute puissante
féminité et maternité et puis il y a
aussi le jour après ma rencontre avec le
gynécologue spécialiste de la chirurgie
réparatrice surnommé l'homme qui répare
les femmes
le docteur denis mukwege peut-être que
vous le connaissez et il m'apprend que
dans l'est de son pays la république
démocratique du congo dans la région du
kivu et dans la ville de ponzi où il a
fondé son hôpital il a depuis 1999
opéré
plus de cinquante mille femmes de ce qui
est utilisé comme une arme de guerre le
viol
je suis ce crime universelle qui
malheureusement existe depuis des
siècles et des siècles roi de la loi du
silence 10% seulement le déclare fait
que pour ces femmes il n'y a pas de jour
d'après l'acte hyperviolents touche à
l'intégrité physique et psychique avec
des conséquences mal connu l'état de
stress post traumatique des troubles
apparaissent et cela entraîne chez ces
femmes des très grandes souffrances
morales liées à des réminiscences qui
entraîne des conduites d'hypervigilance
des conduites dissociant tu le viol
marque et empêchent de vivre de parler
des mets de travail et un esprit
contraint dans un corps meurtri et pour
revenir à panzi un très grand nombre de
survivantes sont à nouveau victime parce
que ce crime est impuni
parce que opérés ne suffit pas alors le
docteur mokobé met en place un
accompagnement post opératoire global la
maison des femmes là les femmes les plus
vulnérables
elles ont entre 12 et 20 ans sont
accueillis et ont accès à des formations
professionnalisantes à la scolarité
elles ont accès à une aide médicalisée à
des soins psychiques à une aide
juridique et dans ce contexte à la
demande des survivantes je me suis rendu
à la maison des femmes
nous sommes sans 2014 et je constate
alors que le traumatisme est arrivée par
le corps rien de spécifique d'accessible
et d'adapter n'est proposée à celui ci
alors je décide de mettre en place un
programme d'activité physique
je vais même un peu plus loin je décide
de le pérenniser
en transmettant son savoir-faire tout
mon savoir être toute mon expérience de
sportive à franck pour que à son tour
ils puissent transmettre à ces femmes
toute l'année le sport parce que je suis
convaincu du fait de de ce que j'ai vécu
pendant des années au quotidien je suis
convaincu de ses valeurs
je suis convaincu de ses bienfaits parce
que je suis d'une militante une grande
je défends la les droits humains parce
que je suis femme combattante mère parce
que c'est inacceptable
à l'occasion de la première séance quand
je les ai vus sont arrivés j'ai vu dans
leurs yeux de la tristesse j'ai vu
qu'elle était ailleurs et j'ai j'avais
vraiment l'impression qu'elle était
morte à l'intérieur d'elle-même
la première chose que nous faisons c'est
nous saluer oui le salut traditionnel
qu'on peut retrouver dans karaté nous
sommes tout en kimono et se saluent
marque et pose le respect qu'on a les
unes pour les autres notre histoire est
aussi là la confiance mutuelle qu'on va
qu'on a à partager cet instant important
alors évidemment elle il ya une grande
attente quant à savoir se défendre mais
finalement ce ne seront que 20 minutes
de leur passé ensemble et je me demande
jusqu'où est ce que je pourrais aller
quelle est leur rapport à leur corps
quelle est leur rapport à l'autre et
nous commençons
par un échauffement en mettant le corps
en mouvement en trottinant nous
mélangeons nous découvrons et puis la
part au hasard d'une épaule qui ce qui
viendrait de moi on touche l'épaule est
ce qu'elles vont accepter de se faire
toucher est ce qu elles vons autorisé à
toucher
elle rit elles sont surprises
et puis nous allons nous concentrer sur
le sur la respiration parce que le coeur
s'est emballé alors la respiration la
décontraction et nous allons travailler
les muscles du périnée lors ses muscles
pour qu'elles les visualise et pour quel
et contracte je leur parle de leur anus
je leur parle de leur vulve je leur
parle aussi du haras et de l'énergie
vitale et je leur apprends à faire un
coup de poing et lorsqu'elles le font je
leur apprends à pousser un cri
je leur montre alors elles elles sont
gênées sans surprise elle ne crie pas
elle ne crie pas mais elles sont bien
attentive et séance après séance
ce corps
crispés tendus inexistant devient plus
souple plus agiles elles sont plus à
l'écouté d'elle-même et parfois il ya de
la colère qui sort dans le cri enfin
pousser il ya des émotions qui arrive
qui les submerge et qu'elle maîtrise
elles sont belles forte courageuse elle
retrouve leur humanité et ce travail là
je les fais pendant deux ans pendant
deux ans tous les dix jours par an je
les rejoins je continue la pratique en
continuant à former franck et est à voir
à quel point il a évolué jusqu'à cette
année 2016 ou sandra une des survivantes
me dit qu'elle veut enseigner aux femmes
pour qu'elles ne soient pas ou plus
victimes et l'art je me dis mais c'est
aller bien au delà de toutes mes
espérances
c'est pas elle n'a pas seulement
retrouvez-les estime d'elle-même elle a
pas seulement elle nous
et pas seulement réapproprier son corps
elle elle a pensé au jour d'après et
fight for dignity aînés pour accompagner
les femmes de la maison dorcas est aussi
depuis peu depuis mars 2018 en france
grâce au docteur rada à thème qui a lui
aussi gynécologue qui elle aussi à la
fonda la maison des femmes de saint
denis a mis en place un programme
holistique tous les jeudis les femmes
viennent et pratique le karaté
voilà fait fort dignity aussi c'est un
c'est de la recherche actions qu'on a
mis en place pour mesurer l'impact de la
pratique sur ses héroïnes
et pour que demain nous pourrons nous
plantions d'autres graines d'espoir en
afghanistan en colombie en république
centrafricaine force10 nitti existent
pour que ces femmes arrivent aux pense
toujours d'après le jour d'après c'est
aussi de notre responsabilité collective
agir et d assaut ceux qui aident à
reconstruire et je suis intimement
convaincu je sais que le sport participe
à retrouver la dignité perdue le sport
aide à la cause des droits humains et de
la paix merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]